Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones and
speak to a few more people, you can join the
discord through which we take phone calls
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
It's a great system.
It really, really is.
Why don't we go next to Dean from the state
of Ohio, Dean?
You were on the air.
Hello.
You hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: Oh, my first time caller.
Thank you.
Glad to talk to you, David.
Pleasure and I'm a current college student
and they put a basically a Campsie class,
a comparative politics.
And I was curious, in your opinion on parliamentary
democracies, because right now in the US,
we have kind of a very strong gridlock in
our Senate system.
And I'm not obviously, I prefer presidential
systems, but you know, if we had a parliamentary
democracy where we could, I guess, effectively
get more things done, do you think the U.S.
would be a better or worse country for it?
It's kind of a broad question, but my
Speaker 1: general belief on this and I've
talked about it a little bit before, is that
I think that a parliamentary system would
bring actually many good things to the United
States where you would have, you know, a system
where you have the leader of the party with
the greatest representation in the Legislature
becoming.
Typically, it would be like the prime minister
or the chancellor rather than a directly elected
president.
I generally think it would be an improvement
for the United States, although I have had
some concerns that there is a lot of really
crazy extremists here and that really horrible
parties which have no official representation
right now could end up having some official
representation in that.
There's certainly a danger to that.
But, you know, it's a very hypothetical.
It's merely an academic question because the
US is not going to change to a parliamentary
system anytime soon.
I'm not like Trump or I go the U.S. will never
at no point soon, right?
At no point soon.
And so I think that we have to try to improve
things in other in other ways.
Of course, yeah, but no, I like parliamentary
systems as a general principle.
Speaker 5: And I guess as a slight addendum
to that question.
We have a mix in the US of a single member
districts that we elected to represent people,
and then we have a proportional system.
Yes.
Do you think we would be better off?
We went to 100 percent proportional.
I know there's pros and cons of both, but
it just seems like we have a Senate that disproportionately
represents Republicans, even though they have
a less percentage overall in the United States.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Look, the Senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic.
I've talked about this before.
It's not representative.
You have something like the senators representing.
I'm trying to get the number right.
It's like 34 percent of the population.
Senators representing 34 percent of the population
control half of the votes, which is fundamentally
unrepresentative and undemocratic.
Again, it's one of these things where there
is no way to deny that that's the case, and
it's just not going to change any time soon.
And so I wonder about the.
The prudence of focusing on it, I want to
make sure people understand this.
The Senate is fundamentally not Democratic
and not representative, but OK, so then what
do we do with that and do we just focus on
that and ignore everything else that we could
be working on?
That doesn't seem prudent, either.
Speaker 5: Oh, but of course, David, my apologies,
I will try to come if I call again next time
to get a more pragmatic question.
I was more of an actor.
Speaker 1: No, no, I'm not criticizing that.
I'm only making it like, in other words, I'm
saying you are 100 percent spot on about these
issues and I agree with you and I talk about
them as well.
And I wonder, what is the balance of like
activism capital that should be spent on one
thing versus the other?
When these things seem very ingrained now,
the counterpoint would be David, if you don't
try to activate around these things, they're
going to remain the way they are.
And that's a good point, too.
You know, so I don't know where our pragmatic
versus idealist balance should be.
Is a much David.
My pleasure.
All right.
Extraordinary phone call there.
Love it.
Let's go next to Michael from Berlin, New
Jersey.
Michael, your next.
Speaker 3: Hi, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing all right, you sound
like you're talking through a voice modulator.
Speaker 3: I know I had say,
Speaker 1: OK, what's going on?
Speaker 3: I just wanted to, I guess, explain
the experience at the polls yesterday, I know
I worked as a poll worker, OK in New Jersey,
and I just wanted to explain my experience
that it was actually a great experience.
I felt like I was really doing a Democratic
thing.
OK.
Unfortunately, it didn't work out the way
I wanted it.
I wanted it to, but but it's OK because I
felt like I actually did my duty.
So were the man actually some curious?
Speaker 1: Were there poll workers trying
to election-year in some way during during
their work?
Speaker 3: Yeah, we did actually have the
problem.
They were within the one 100 foot zone and
people were complaining outside.
Speaker 1: But those were poll workers or
these were just people, people trying to campaign
there.
Speaker 3: Campaign ads.
OK, OK.
Speaker 1: Did you have any issues like on?
There was this video.
There was a picture of some guy all maggot
out working the polls.
You didn't have anything like that.
Speaker 3: That's good.
Yeah.
Thankfully not.
But we were in a rural area in New Jersey,
so like close to the Pine Barrens.
So maybe you would have that in the like in
a big city, maybe or or in a suburban area?
OK.
That's what I want.
We were in teams like you couldn't just be
a poll worker and not have a like, I was in
charge of bringing the votes back into the
central location, the town hall and I was
teamed up with a Republican and it happened
to be a woman.
Actually, I was the only male in the whole
group out of 12.
I was the only male and actually turned out
to be a Great Dane.
And she was such a what was it?
She was definitely the opposite of a low information
person, like she was very spartan, but she's
very capable and competent.
So, I mean, I guess I was just I'm I'm thinking
negatively about Republicans, much less than
she.
I just couldn't believe that she was a Republican.
That's how competent.
And she just wanted to share that, that she
was very, I don't know, competent and I would
gladly work with her again.
Now I'm curious,
Speaker 1: why was it even coming up, what
people's party affiliations were?
In other words, isn't it?
What is it?
Because there's supposed to be a split of
Democrats and Republicans?
Speaker 3: Yes.
Right?
If you return, I was responsible for returning
the ballots, right?
And you can't do that by yourself.
You have to have a fair delegation.
So you have to have a Republican and a Democrat.
Got it.
All right.
Well, it
Speaker 1: sounds like it was a good experience
I would encourage more people to to become
poll workers.
Speaker 3: Yes, I would do I would do the
same.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
All right, Michael from Berlin, New Jersey.
Great to hear from you.
A lot of people, in fact in the audience,
emailed me and said, David, I was a poll worker
here.
I was a poll worker there.
Quite quite compelling stuff.